- Aux sacs citoyens. Elle n'y
Luc, bonst-ce qu'on
fait?
- On demande aux citoyens d'en
faire plus d'être responsable.
La villertient et
lorsqu'on marche sur les
trottoirs, surtout printemps moi
j'ai fait des campagnes de
sensibilprès des
citoyensnd on voit un
gobelet de café, il n'est pas
arrivé là tout seul le gobelet.
Il y a quelqu'un qu'il a bu et
qu'il a jeté àa jeté àa jeté àat
que la neige était pour le
couvrir. Ou les petits cadeaux
des chiens, ou lesns, ou lesns,t
le monde se dit que ça n'a pas
de bon sens qu'elle avait les
salles. Mais elle ne s'est pas
salie tout ça villut ça villut a
responsabilité des citoyens.
C'est pour ça qu'on met des
poubelles un peu partout dans
coins de rue pour que
les gens les utilisent. On ne
peut pas toujours refaire faire
et refaire. Il faut que les gens
ensibilisés et
responsabilisés. Il est supposé
avoir de9Ovées de pr=.>>
dans les parts, dans les
ruelles, c'est pour ça qu'on a
les projets de ruelles verts.
responsabilité de tout
le monde se respecter et de
respecter la ville.
- Luc est-ce que le citoyen peut
plus? Est-ce que la
ville peut en faire plus pour
que les citoyens fassent plus?
- Oui mais moi j'y crois juste à
moitié. Je pense que les corvées
citoyennes c'est souvent les
mêmes personnes, difficile à
organiser, choisir le week-end,
faut le faire c'est le fun quied
Bergeron a raison. Un sac devant
chez toi tu le remplis tu as sae
fait ça ça va beaucoup changer.
Les citoyens plus consciencieux
qu'avant, les propriétaires dece
fond il y a déjà 20 ans. Quand
ça fondait avant c'était unslale
chien. Maintenant ce n'est plus
le cas. Tu ne peux pas marcher
dans un parc au printemps avanÇl
sera toujours une salle pour
plusieurs raisons. D'abord, daùs
adresses qui donnent sur les
savoir d'où vient la saleté. Ça
peut venir de n'importe quelled.
Deuxième chose, c'est un vélo
les escaliers en direct sur la
rue. Il n'y a pas de local à
ordures. À Paris, à Barcelone
etc. il y a un concierge et une
salle à ordures. Toutes sortes
de choses font que laver les
salles.
- Tant mieux s'il y en a
davantage qui font davantage
mais est-ce que les villes et
les arrondissements doivent en
faire plus?
Les budgets pour en faire plus?
- Elle devrait l'avoir. Il y a
des brigades propreté sur les
grandes rues commerciales, mais
la responsabilité des
arrondissements c'est aussi de
mettre des poubelles au coin des
rues. Quand tu n'as pas de
poubelle, le papier tu le
laisses tomber. Ton Kleenex
aussi. Des masques aussi. Ça
c'est un problème. Moi quand
j'étais maire de mon
demandes citoyens en disant: si
vous ne voulez pas qu'on jette
nos déchets donnez-nous des
poubelles. C'est là qu'on a fait
des poubelles de rues
recyclables. Ça on devrait en
avoir davantage. Pour permettre
aux gens de pouvoir le faire ne
pas leur donner d'excuses.
- Luc, est-ce que les
arrondissements doivent en faire
plus?
- Oui. Notamment sur tous les
coins de ruelles, dans les
quartiers centraux, les gens
vont porter leur sac à tout
moment. On a commencé, ça
commence sur le platea à
installer des gros bacs pour que
les gens mètrent des poubelles
pour que les gens mettent leur
sac entre les collectes. La
personne qui habite dans un uni
et qui a raté le journée des
poubelles ne va pas la garder.
Ça 25. Les gens vont se dire
sûrement après ça toujours des
poubelles je vais alors ajouter
un sac. Il faut couper ses
effets cumulatifs. Il faut des
bacs au coin des ruelles
suffisamment lourd pour ne pas
être volé.
- Pour le monde municipal, c'est
intéressant aujourd'hui, parce
que le maire Marchand a gagné
une manche importante contre le
gouvernement du Québec. Qui
jonglait avec imposer des
conditions avant de lui donner
un décret pour faire son fameux
tramway. Finalement il n'y aura
pas de conditions.
- Alors on a été élu en disant:
nous allons faire le tramway.
Il y avait beaucoup de partis au
municipales et l'élection estuié
le tramway, les citoyens
se sont prononcés c'est
ça la légitimité. C'est
ça la capacité de dire; bien
on fait confiance à des élus.
- Il a refusé les conditions,
cette obligation de tenir un
projet de
tramway. Annie, victoire du
monde municipal qui a son décret
est une liberté de gérer ses
projets?
- Oui, moi ce qui m'inquiétait
là-dedans c'est de voir l'impact
le municipal. Tout a sauté quand
on ne parlait de partager la
rue, diviser et changer les
voies à la circulation les
véhicules. C'est là que Québec a
dit non ça n'a pas de bon sens.
Mais ça l'aménagement c'est unee
municipal. Je suis contente que
dans la même semaine on n'en a
parlé que Suzanne Roy, la
présidente, l'ancien président
de l'union de la municipalité à
choisi la kayak. Elle j'espère
qu'elle sera là pour tenir
l'effort pour les
responsabilités des deux
paliers. Il y a eu un mélange
des pouvoirs je comprends que le
municipal est un palier
intéressant parce qu'on
travaille au quotidien sur des
projets concrets avec les gens.
Au provincial on fait des lois,
on fait des gros projets mais on
ne voit pas les résultats tout
de suite. Je pense que certains
députés auraient peut-être voulu
se mêler de l'aménagement.
- Il s'emmêlait pas mal en
disant ce René-Lévesque on ne
veut pas si on ne passa. Le
victoire pour le monde municipal
selon vous?
- Énorme. D'ailleurs bravo à
Bruno Marchand. Qui a fait face
à un barrage de quatre ministres
et aussi bravo Monsieur Legault.
Parce que reculer quand son
parti a avancé dans un contexte
particulier, où les
conservateurs les menaces dans
six comtés autour de Québec, où
les conservateurs font des
assemblées publiques précisément
sur ce projet-là, de reculer en
disant non finalement on va
aller avec le projet de tramway
parce que c'est bien, pour le
bien public c'est ce qu'il faut
faire. Et aussi parce que le
monde municipal s'est mobilisé,
ça prononce du courage. Bravo à
ces deux grands politiciens.
- Parce que le tramway à Québec
divise beaucoup. Le tramway
divise en faite la majorité des
gens se dise contre ce projet.
On a l'impression qu'ils
pourront moins bien circuler.
- Le GIEC lundi. Il faut plus de
projets pour les gens de
circuler en ville. On a des
projets, il faut aller vers
l'électrique. Ce projet est là.
Lorsqu'on parle de circulation,
surtout de transport, c'est
toujours un projet. Que ce soit
Montréal, que ce soit Québec
c'est un projet qui dérange peu
importe qu'on avance qu'on
recule. On a eu le même exemple
à Québec. On la Montréal sur le
métro, sur le thème. On
l'activait encore une fois.
- On n'avait pas prononcé le mot